when i think of christmas stories
charles dickens a christmas carol is one
of the first that comes to mind
even if you don't celebrate christmas
the story is more so
about the spirit of giving and
forgiveness
being wary of how we treat others around
us
and knowing that it's never too late to
change our ways
no matter how stubborn we are
oh
the story begins on christmas eve in the
cold streets of
london down one particularly dreary road
we come to the office of scrooge and
marley
where ebenezer scrooge sits at his desk
going over his accounts
and counting his money perhaps his
favorite pastime
opposite him sits his clerk bob cratchit
who is struggling to stop himself from
shivering
forgive me for asking again sir
but why don't you just buy some coal for
the furnace so we don't have to freeze
and waste good money burning coal why
don't i just throw my money straight
into the furnace
man up and put on another layer ebenezer
scrooge was not one to part with his
money
nor did he share in the christmas spirit
ever since his business partner marley
had passed away
seven years ago you'd be hard-pressed to
call anyone his
friend shortly after they are visited by
scrooge's nephew fred
who invites him to his annual christmas
party and as
his custom his uncle tells him he's not
interested
no just like i told you last time
christmas parties are a waste of money
as fred continues trying to persuade his
uncle inward
two men collecting for charity evening
gentlemen
anyone spare a penny for the poor and
homeless
no not one now if you don't mind
we are very busy i can see that sir
merry christmas to you and your family
hamburg scrooge replied with his usual
bitterness
and disdain
as it grew late scrooge finally decided
it was time to call it a night but
little did he know
his night was only just beginning
when scrooge lay in his bed he heard the
rattling of chains
and the sound of something heavy
scraping against the floor
who's there he called out but no one
answered
as he sat up from his bed before him was
the
spirit of his ex-business partner
ali is is that you
how can this be i'm afraid so old friend
as you can see i am forced to wander for
eternity
held down by these chains and my
misdeeds
it's been seven years why do you visit
me now
because i fear you are destined to
suffer a similar fate as myself
our greed and obsession for wealth has
destroyed the lives of countless
individuals but we were too blind to see
tonight you will be visited by three
spirits
they will show you the error of your
ways i hope only you realize it is not
too late to make amends
i must go now goodbye old friend
scrooge lay in his bed in a state of
disbelief
eventually he dozed off waiting for the
spirit smallie had mentioned
all of a sudden a bright light flashed
through the room and scrooge stood up on
his bed
a woman dressed in white stood before
him
did marley send you scrooge started
no ebenezer i am the ghost of christmas
past
come with me and let her see how you
ended up down this
path she took scrooge's hand and within
a flash
they were in his old boarding school the
common room was full of children
playing and having fun but scrooge
notices a younger version of himself
in the corner alone reading he recounts
the only person he truly called friend
was his sister fan when she died
the part of him that valued friendship
also died
they are now at a party hosted by
scrooge's first boss
mr feswig this man gave scrooge his
first
real opportunity in life and he speaks
of mr feswig
as a father figure to him the next
memory they relive is the moment
scrooge's ex-fiancee bell
ends their relationship he acknowledges
this was his fault as he
often neglected her caring more for his
money
finally the spirit takes him to belle's
house the same christmas marley had
passed away
he looks through the window and sees
belle and her family around a christmas
dinner
as happy as can be scrooge is left
distraught at the realization of what he
could have had
enough i demand to leave this place
i'm done with these games and so the
spirit returned him to his bed chamber
the next time scrooge woke it was to a
thundering roar
come on ebenezer get up we have places
to go and people to see
before scrooge did a giant man dressed
in a green fur robe
i do not care to be mocked by my past
anymore
leave me alone well it's a good thing i
am the ghost of christmas present
now get up so we can see how your
actions affect those around you now
scrooge took the giant's hand and they
flew through the streets of london
they end up in the house of his clerk
bob cratchit
as they enjoy a christmas feast this
can't be all they're having
there must be more in the kitchen this
is all bob can afford of the salary you
pay him
what of bob's youngest son where is he
the spirit takes ebenezer into a room
where tiny tim
lays in bed sick the boy is sick
why does bob not buy him medicine
because with what you pay him he cannot
afford medicine
and if he does not buy medicine will the
boy if the course of events do not
change
then this will be his last christmas
scrooge witnesses bob pick up tiny tim
and carry him to the dinner table
despite this situation the family enjoy
their meal
and smiles echo throughout the room none
bigger than tiny tims
how can they be so happy when they have
so little
because there is more to this world than
money
scrooge says nothing in response he can
only look down as he's overcome by the
feeling of guilt and shame
the spirit takes him through the town
where the celebrations continue
eventually he lifts his robe to reveal
two hideous children
what is the meaning of this these are
your children
ignorance and want they look sickly
what has happened to them of course for
these you show concern
i have shown you all there is to see
scrooge returned to his bed chamber once
again
this time scrooge is woken by an icy
chill
his windows are closed but his room is
freezing
before him stands the last spirit a
hooded figure dressed in black
are you the third spirit or the ghost of
death itself
scrooge inquires but receives no reply
if i've seen my past and present then
you must be the ghosts of christmas yet
to come
again he receives no reply but the
spirit reaches out encouraging scrooge
to take its hand
as scrooge reaches out they appear on a
street next to two businessmen
who discussed the death of a mysterious
individual
you know people only attended the
funeral because lunch was provided
yeah i heard the undertaker and his
staff stole
all of his possessions before they
buried the body
so i was the old miser right next to
them stood an old couple who heard the
man who had died
was in fact their creditor the two
rejoice
and even celebrate his passing anxious
to know the man's name scrooge begs the
spirit to tell him
but he remains silent the spirit takes
him to a cemetery
where he sees bob cratchit and his
family mourning the loss of tiny tim
a scrooge begins to cry he turns to a
tombstone that no one has visited
when he kneels down he sees the name
ebenezer scrooge
please spirit i do not want to die a
lonely miserable man
i see the error in my ways change my
fate and i promise i will help those in
need
the spirit shook its head and pointed to
bob cratchit and his family
when ebenezer turned to face them he was
back in his bed
ebenezer scrooge woke on christmas
morning a changed man
he jumped from his bed and ordered for
an enormous turkey to be sent to bob
cratchit
he found the charity collectors from
earlier and made a
sizeable donation he even attended his
nephew fred's party
and before the night was done he paid
bob and his family a visit
he agreed that bob deserved a pay rise
and that he should work
less hours so he could spend more with
his family
he would also pay for tiny tim's
medicine and provide gifts for all the
children
from that day on ebenezer scrooge would
treat everyone with kindness
generosity and compassion he will embody
the spirit of christmas
every year as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
wishing you all a merry christmas and
happy holidays
you